qui a envie de me dire des choses qui ne
m'a jamais dit Guillaume je pense
moi j'ai vraiment envie de passer plus
de temps avec vous et j'aimerais qu'on
habite ensemble on offre
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas obligé de me concerner votre
truc non mais j'en ai marre que vous me
traitiez comme ça comme une petite
michto j'aimerais bien qu'on habite
ensemble écoute je veux dormir chez vous
tous les soirs maintenant déjà est-ce
que vous allez faire déjà vous allez
dormir
et après on verra où chef vous avez vu
le vernis qu'il a fait spécialement pour
vous demain c'est léopard versatile et
excuse-moi pour lui servent une goutte
de sang
là c'est un truc de fou Géraldine mon
bébé vous dire quoi si tu as quelque
chose à me dire que tu m'as jamais dit
mais pas pas qui me concerne ça peut me
concerne toi non je vous trouve très en
forme plutôt très embotée
sur toi ma chérie est-ce que tu as un
truc que tu m'as jamais dit moi voilà
oui ah oui alors je suis très intrigué
parce que hier vous m'avez dit que vous
connaissiez mon week-end et en fait
comment vous savez pourquoi qui comment
je sais tout
mais ça m'a impressionné en fait je me
suis dit des micro chez moi il y a aucun
micro chez vous vous savez le seul micro
c'est dans mon coeur donc vous savez ce
que je fais ce weekend
je vous en parlerai tout à l'heure
ok mais vous savez que c'est quand même
bizarre parce que personne le sait en
fait moi je le sais
je le sais
et j'aurais des antennes là-bas
ah oui d'accord ok
donc calmez-vous Géraldine partout cette
professionnelle méfiez-vous d'accord
mais vous avez des gens qui travaillent
pour vous
croyez vraiment que l'autre la Sergueï
il travaille au kg
[Applaudissements]
je te dis tout moi déjà là donc j'ai pas
vraiment de secret mais je vois sur
quelle pente tu essaies de m'emmener
et je n'irai pas je non je peux je peux
avoir un truc c'est que j'ai un vrai
coup de coeur pour Benaim par contre et
je l'ai dit à toute l'équipe et tout
crush c'est vraiment un coup de coeur
qui s'est raté à 30 ans près et c'est
pas ça de ta mère
elle t'a laissé des DM bien Naïm sur
insta c'est on s'écrit on s'écrit on
s'envoie des petits trucs pour l'instant
c'est rien de ouf on s'envoie des petits
mots mais je compte passer la seconde
très rapidement et après le 2 ouais
après le 2 octobre
[Rires]
on a un rendez-vous vous en parlera le 2
octobre rendez-vous
c'est l'anniversaire de mon père je veux
pas de [ __ ]
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire
que tu m'as jamais dit que tu aimes les
vieilles que Valérie
[Applaudissements]
elle part pas
elle s'est pris une balle perdure
non non j'ai une petite requête mais
alors vraiment toute simple et très
sérieuse être payé
il y a plein de gens qui vous ont de
temps en temps au téléphone apparemment
ça j'aimerais bien qu'un jour vous
m'appeliez mais comme ça juste pour
bonjour c'est Cyril quand tu sois à côté
d'une borne
c'est tout simple
je fais plusieurs modèles allô ma Daniel
ça va ma chérie c'est Cyril ah ça me
fait plaisir que tu m'appelles Cyril
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
je t'appelle je t'appelle aux alentours
de 2h du matin 2h30
oui qu'est-ce que tu fais
rien mais je sens que je vais faire des
trucs dans très peu de temps
Daniel je voulais juste te dire que tu
étais là demain dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu dors
je dormais jusqu'à maintenant tu es bien
réveillé là oui tu es nul
j'ai un petit filet approvision
simplement
tu peux faire des courses ah oui
tu aimerais pas rajouter une belle
aubergine
vous êtes complètement fou
vous appelez qui autour de la table
vraiment régulièrement
j'ai des choses à leur dire
que tu as quelque chose à me dire que tu
ne m'as jamais vous m'avez rendu heureux
directement mais vous dans la
constitution de l'équipe que vous avez
faite cette année parce que moi j'ai un
problème c'est que je ne parle à
personne donc en loge je suis dans mon
coin et j'ai découvert quelqu'un qui est
venu vers moi c'est la première fois
personne ne vient ici me dire bonjour
pas du tout Nino et oui
viens vers moi il est il est touchant il
est très agréable et je ne connais pas
encore quoi
et donc ouais je voulais vous remercier
parce que c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive et je cherche la première fois
que quelqu'un te parle quelqu'un de
sympathique d'intelligent d'ouvert je
connaissais pas et là voilà il est là
donc
l'américaine est un peu hautaine
quand elle est intéressée oui je l'aime
bien j'aime bien j'ai appris à la
découvrir toujours un peu arrogante
totem à l'américaine mais voilà elle n'a
pas toutes les qualités mais puis elle
est pas là tout le temps donc ça va
[Rires]
le mec est fou le mec est fou tous les
jours je vais lui dire bonjour il est
dans son petit coin c'est vrai
dû gagner un procès bravo
merci merci bravo merci merci à lui
merci à lui non mais c'est vrai c'est la
base c'est pas que mon avocat c'est
l'avocat de tout le tout tout le gratin
moi je suis réparti des du dauphinois
il y a le gratin et moi je suis le
dauphinois en dessous oui ma chérie
est-ce que tu as quelque chose que tu
m'as jamais dit non mais je voulais vous
poser une question vous qui avez tout
qu'est-ce qui vous ferait plaisir pour
votre anniversaire
très bonne question
moi ce que ce qui m'apporte le plus
c'est l'amour des autres bah voilà c'est
ça que je voulais dire
et si tu peux passer chez choper
raitateurs Béatrice l'Amérique quoi ah
mais c'est vrai hein Béatrice ben vous
en avez beaucoup donc ça tombe bien vous
êtes vous êtes comblés alors bah oui ça
va vous sinon super merci c'est tout
c'est tout ce que vous aviez me dire bon
c'est déjà pas mal vous êtes déjà sorti
avec un acteur très célèbre
[Applaudissements]
je crois savoir qui c'est
Spider-Man
peut-être l'homme élastique le 4
fantastique
on va se calmer comment on dit chaudière
en anglais
[Applaudissements]
c'est pareil qu'en français c'est
frisquet les chaudières t'inquiète pas
c'est pareil non non mais je crois que
vous avez un sixième sens ouais poser
des questions
non mais est-ce que est-ce que tu peux
me le dire dans l'oreille moi
à personne parce que je suis je persuadé
que je ne connais pas le gars on les
connaît tous je le dirai le 3 si s'il y
a un débat
mais regarde pas la télé
les Américains oh je suis occupés déjà
il dort à cette heure-ci tu crois quoi
je ne veux pas que leur causer de
prendre pas
est-ce que tu peux me dire dans
l'oreille t'inquiète je te jure je
dirais
une tombe
[Applaudissements]
à moi
dans le Lot qui est en ce moment loup a
des problèmes dans les dans les dans les
médias people
qui n'était pas du tout à l'époque et du
coup je ne veux pas du tout
s'il vous plaît
s'affiche sur votre écran
sachez et je ne dirai rien on a la même
passion pour les marrons les marrons
non non non non
c'est Phil Collins
juste le prénom Cyril
il était célibataire qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train de dévoiler là
elle en a trop dit ou pas assez voilà
la dernière fois nous a dit qu'il était
sorti avec haricots
tu as tout sorti avec des stars ici non
mais sans déconner c'est vrai mais lui
regarde lui il te rappelle ton aventure
avec qui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait des meufs il y avait le choix
entre mickeywan et elle choisit c'est
toi
toi tu es conne qui me passingers
tu as déjà eu une meuf elle est arrivée
comme ça tu as levé le choix entre toi
et Mickey qu'elle t'a choisi frère ça
dépend de Los Angeles monsieur
l'écran va s'afficher l'adresse
d'optique 2000
le plus proche de chez elle c'était
avant les opérations esthétiques de
Gilbert Montagné
pas tout le temps on était dans les
mêmes soirées à l'hôtel au standard à
Los Angeles toi tu es au standard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s
je suis dégoûté c'est encore Gilles
Verdez
c'est encore que de ma meuf
c'est un truc de ouf
avec d'autres acteurs il était avec Brad
Pitt Tom Cruise le truc il voyait tous
il faut y arriver j'y vais arriver merde
on est
morte qui va encore nous piquer nos meuf
dire ça
[Rires]
mais dans quelle vie frère tu as fait
chaud plus de meuf que Mickey je vous
raconterai un mytho comme ça
est en train de te rendre fou tout
simplement
c'est pas possible mais qu'est-ce que tu
faisais là-bas
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
de quoi
vous voyez bien non mais ça raconte-nous
juste concrètement une histoire j'étais
en vacances à Los Angeles
[Applaudissements]
tu étais tout seul toi non j'étais avec
un collègue et ami tous les ans pendant
10 ans
on avait nos habitudes on partait tous
les ans à Los Angeles on fait des
soirées dans les hôtels au Château
Marmont on allait souvent j'étais très
VIP au Château Marmont
il m'écrivait encore tous les ans pour
me souhaiter la bonne année mais c'est
le grand-père
dégueulasse et tout la merlok là
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai marre le plus bel hôtel de Los
Angeles
il y a que les vipères
c'est pas si cher au mois d'août c'est
pas si cher je l'ai tous les ans j'avais
des prix j'étais là-bas
c'est là où j'ai vécu toutes mes soirées
au quels sont les trucs que je peux pas
raconter en tracteur américain
hallucinant
comme elle j'étais VIP château Marmande
et on allait faire des soirées au
standard ou Mickey Rourke était là
standard c'est quoi le standard c'est un
hôtel un autre hôtel de Los Angeles plus
moderne il y avait une soirée en bas et
parfois Mickey
et tout c'est moi et moi et avec ma
petite tête là comme ça et bah c'est pas
lui qui qui sortait toujours avec les
plus belles filles oui monsieur ça a
l'air de et tu t'es réveillé à quelle
heure
parce que là c'est parti
je partais à New York et c'est vrai que
je suis à côté de petite française avec
Molière là donc
il a toujours été beau il a toujours été
dégueulasse
il est extrêmement élégant
[Applaudissements]
que vous me fassiez un montage entre une
fonction de Mickey
et vous allez juger par vous-même voilà
donc
il est arrivé déjà à mon avis il était
devant la boîte en train de jouer de la
guitare
maintenant moi sans rigoler on dirait on
dirait une chaleur ou pas
donc là donc là attendez donc là je
voudrais que vous fassiez à chaque fois
vous mettez la photographie donc là tu
arrives en boîte tu vois Mickey la
Mickey qui te Chine et là 2 minutes
après tu as l'autre gars qui arrive
voilà merci voilà
il a une meuf il y a des meufs il y a
des meufs je vais partir avec le gars là
à mon avis
à l'époque
mais là frère donc là toi tu étais en
français
[Musique]
normalement des gars comme ça et tu
démarres comme ça il y a Christophe on a
qui fait
Gilles Verdez
était connu au standard Los Angeles
Tom Cruise Brad Pitt très vite
il s'est cru au même niveau que
de conquête enquête Gilles Verdez est
devenu celui qu'on lui surnommait à Los
Angeles le mythomane
aux chevaux gras
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à quel moment tu sortais de la temboise
[Rires]
alors aujourd'hui tu es magnifique je
peux te dire que tu pourrais séduire les
plus belles mais d'ailleurs fait tout
est magnifique
quand on voit Fatou on se dit voilà
c'est vrai que là on s'est dit voilà on
se pose des questions tout simplement on
dirait qu'il y a pas que le physique ah
oui mais voilà tu sais quand même tu
sais que ça peut plaire ça plaisait non
mais c'est rigoler oui quoi je laisse la
drogue est forte
est-ce que vous avez un truc à me dire
que vous n'avez jamais dit
oui vas te faire [ __ ]
je trouve que vous emmêlez ici de jour
en jour il faut changer je trouve que
vous avez le poil brillant et ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'as contrariée ici bon mon chéri
hier soir je me disais que ça faisait
déjà 5 ans que vous ayez pas pécho de
mes meufs ça pouvait continuer
[Applaudissements]
tu vas voir ce que je peux faire
maintenant le séducteur de l'émission
C'est pas moi
j'ai jamais pris de ma famille
écoute non moi j'aimerais bien juste que
ça dure entre nous comme ça
dure on a envie que ça soit dur
[Applaudissements]
on s'aime très fort et on s'engueule
très fort et j'aime pas quand on
s'engueule donc si on peut être un peu
voilà
t'inquiète ça va durer voilà maintenant
tu sais je veux dire ça va plus
s'arrêter qu'est-ce qu'il veut moi le
prends pas comme une menace mais c'est
plutôt une menace en fait
ta gueule disons que ça fait à peu près
8 ans que je suis là ça fait 8 ans que
tu me dis que je suis le meilleur 8 ans
que tu me dis que je suis un espoir hein
8 ans que je roule j'ai pas décollé
alors alors
c'est pas fini
2 prime régulier ici et je décolle soit
je vais décoller ailleurs sur une autre
chaîne
[Applaudissements]
je crois que le mieux c'est qu'il
décolle ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
fais gaffe on décolores pas de prendre
le mur
sont intéressés
à la télé je t'apprendrai à tirer les
manches à Mykonos sans non c'est bon
merci
tu es juste la graine de café donc tu
vas aller faire un café à tout le monde
là puis tu vas arrêter de nous faire
chier d'accord
c'est bon
d'accord ça a des abdos c'est à ma
droite qu'est-ce que tu veux plus
qu'est-ce que tu veux
mais tu sens encore moi il y a un numéro
un qui demande qu'à sortir
tu vois un peu comme tu vois comme
Damien Thévenot à côté de Sophie Davant
sauf que tu bouges pas moi j'avais prévu
qu'un jour bah tout ton argent on dirait
[Applaudissements]
par contre toi